the infection rates are going up very  very fast and so  something has to be done and we support  the steps the government's put in place  but millions of families across the  country could be heartbroken  by this news having their christmas  plans ripped up  and i'm really frustrated because i  raised this with the prime minister on  wednesday  and he dismissed that and went on to  tell people to have a merry little  christmas only three days later to rip  up their plans and i think the british  public's entitled to  more decisive leadership than that  they're getting confusion  where they need certainty we challenged  the prime minister on wednesday about  this  and he pushed back that challenge and  told people to have a merry little  christmas and then three days later he's  ripping up their plans and  families will be heartbroken across the  country as a result of this